(dissonance)
- Charlie.
Charlie.
- What?
- Are you still awake?
- Yeah.
- I can't sleep either.
I'm just thinking about,
like, the universe, you know?
Like, it's so big, and
there's so much stuff in it,
and there's like, so much that
we don't understand about it.
You know what I mean?
- Yeah, sure.
- What are you thinking about?
- I'm just thinking about
the book I'm reading.
- You're not thinking
about anything?
- No, I'm thinking
about the book
as I read the book.
I'm reading.
- Do you have any more gum?
- No, it's all gone.
- Home, home on the range
where the deer
and the antelope--
- Shh.
(glass breaking, shouting)
- No, wait wait wait,
stop stop stop stop,
please, just stay where you are.
(dissonant music)
Sorry it's cold.
- We'd heard rumors of
a convoy near the river
headed to a military safehouse,
so naturally, we headed west.
We could never have
imagined what met us there.
We lost three of
our best sol-di-ers.
They were brave men,
self-sacrificing,
they had a great look.
They were like--
- I'm sorry to
interrupt you, but...
Bridget?
Bridget, right?
- Um, hi.
- Matt, do you remember?
From camp.
We went to the same camp.
- Oh, hey.
- Hey, this is so weird.
- It's really funny.
- How's it going?
- Good, um,
you know, just doing this.
Um, how about you?
- Good, you know?
Do you still talk to Brian?
- Brian, is he tall?
- No no no no, that's Ryan.
You're thinking of Ryan--
- Matt, do you
mind if I just, um,
what is it that brings
you and your group to--
- The Lazarus Project.
- What is that?
- No, that's the
name of our group.
We're not just some
group, I named us.
- Oh, uh, all right.
Well what brings the
Lazarus Project around here?
- We had heard rumors
there was a working outlet
somewhere in this sector.
Hmm, what is that?
- Yeah, actually, you
came to the right place.
It's right back here.
It only works for a few hours
on the ninth of every month.
Usually in the late
morning or early afternoon.
- How'd you figure that out?
- Oh, well, I just checked
a nearby router box
with a voltage meter, and
after graphing the coordinates,
this seemed like the
most likely building
to still be drawing current.
The monthly thing is just
a fluke of the amperage
in the breaker system.
- So we're gonna play games.
We got three.
So that's good for the
two of us and Myron.
But you guys could probably
switch out for Myron.
He barely plays.
- We don't need any of that.
We're just here to recharge
our radio transmitters.
- Okay, sure.
- We were here first,
though, so I feel like--
- No, that's totally fine.
- Thank you Charlie.
Let's hunker down here til
the outlet starts working.
Bridget, secure the perimeter.
- Okay.
Excuse me, I'm sorry.
Perimeter's secure.
- I could help, Bridget,
I'm not doing anything.
- Hi.
- Hey.
- It's cool, that's a nice vest.
You look very nice.
- Oh, thanks.
It's bulletproof.
- Cool.
- Yeah.
- So do you, uh,
do you like being in
the Lazarus Project?
- Yeah, I like it.
I mean, it's a lot of uh,
running around and securing
perimeters and stuff.
I mean, before this I
worked at this store
that did like, dog clothes and
treats and things like that,
and you know, this
is good, it's fine.
- Mhmm.
- I don't know.
What about you?
How do you, how do
you like your group?
Does your group have a name?
- Um, yeah.
It's, we're called
the Power... Rangers.
- Like the kids show?
- Yes, like that.
- Cool, okay, sure.
- But I'm the
leader of the group.
I'm like the main Power Ranger.
- I'm surprised to hear that.
You know, I just
assumed Charlie was.
- Yeah, uh, no.
He's not.
A lot of people think that,
but he does sort of
like, the boring stuff,
like the math and the
talking and logistics,
and like, what we shouldn't
eat and stuff like that,
but I am like the
main, like the lead,
like the lead uh...
- Power Ranger?
- Yeah.
- Cool.
That's great.
- Yeah.
- What did you do before this?
- I was a soccer coach.
- You miss it?
- Every day.
- We cut north here,
we can hit the water
safely outside the red zone.
- Or you could cut
along the canal.
Might be easier to stay hidden.
- He's right.
- You know, we could use
someone with your skills
on this mission.
You're clearly
brave, intelligent,
you got a great look.
You'd make an
excellent sol-di-er.
- Uh... I don't think I'd--
- How'd you like to join the
Lazarus Project, Charlie?
- Wow, uh,
jeez, I guess I, uh...
- We're live.
- Let's do this.
We don't know when this
thing will go dead,
so we need to move now.
- Wait a second,
Charlie, Myron, and I
camped out here overnight.
- You're just gonna play games.
- No, we're not just
gonna play games,
we brought a lot of fun stuff.
Myron brought an
electric blanket.
- Come on man, just let
them do their thing.
- It's our outlet, we found it.
I order you, uh,
to follow my order.
- What?
- As leader of our group,
I vote to banish
the Lazarus Project
from the beauty salon.
Except for Bridget.
If she wants to stay.
Be fine.
- Seriously?
You guys think
you're a real group?
Do you even have a name?
- You don't have to repeat
what you said to me,
it was clearly a lie.
- Okay.
Um, fine.
Uh, maybe we don't have a name.
Maybe we're not a real group.
Maybe that's okay,
because maybe groups and leaders
aren't always a good thing.
You know?
Maybe we're doing a lot better
just as two best friends.
- I take no offense.
- Shh, just one sec.
- You might be two best friends,
but you'll never
be true sol-di-ers.
- I'm sorry, but
what is this word?
Sol-di-ers?
- Yeah, what do you mean?
- Are you trying
to say "soldiers?"
- Is he trying to
say "soldiers?"
- I really have no idea.
- No, it's spelled S-O-L-D--
- Yeah, it's
definitely "soldiers."
- You thought it
was "sol-di-ers?"
Like a French word?
- How long have
you thought that?
Does he say that word a lot?
- Yeah he does.
- Sol-di-ers?
- Sol-di-ers.
- I get how you
would think that.
- If you only ever
see it in print?
- All right, enough.
Charlie, I guess I
was wrong about you.
I thought you had what it takes
to weather the storms of this--
- Are you saying you
thought I would make
a really good sol-di-er?
- Wow, okay, you know what?
We're done here.
We don't have to negotiate
with these losers.
Let's get out of here.
Lizard?
- Yes sir.
- This isn't over, Charlie.
- Bye Matt.
- Bye.
- Was that guy's name Lizard?
- He called him Lizard, yeah.
- It's probably a
nickname, right?
- It's gotta be a nickname.
Nobody's named Lizard.
♪ A discouraging word ♪
♪ And the sky da da-- ♪
- I don't know that part.
- I was following you, though.
- Okay.
- I wish we had a screen.
- It's fine.
♪ Home, home on the range ♪
♪ Where the deer and
the antelope play ♪
♪ Where seldom is heard ♪
♪ A discouraging word ♪
♪ And the skies are
all cloudy all-- ♪
- Not cloudy?
- Okay, I think--
♪ Day ♪
- Nice.
- Nice, all right, cool.
- That was fun, okay.
- Well, uh, who's next?
- So I'll go after him.
♪ Give my regards to Broadway ♪
♪ Remember me to Harold Square ♪
♪ Tell all the boys
on 42nd Street ♪
♪ That I'll soon be there ♪
- [Charlie] Aw, jeez.
I guess that's it.
- [Matt] Yeah, okay.
Good one guys.
- [Myron] I guess
I'll go next month.
(dissonant music)